Robert Hooke: The Leonardo of England
Without a doubt, Robert Hooke was one of the
greatest minds in British history.
His scientific contributions spanned physics,
astronomy, horology, microscopy, paleontology,
and even architecture.
And yet, he is nowhere near as well-known
today as his peers.
The Royal Society believes that Hooke’s
scientific career can be split into three
parts.
First were the early years when Hooke had
the inquisitive mind and the ambitions necessary
to become a great scientist.
Then came the apex of his profession around
the time of the Great Fire of London in 1666.
His architectural work redesigning and reconstructing
many buildings devastated by the fire brought
him great wealth.
And, lastly, there is the third stage of Hooke’s
life where bitterness and rivalries with other
scientists overshadowed his contributions
and ensured that he became a footnote of history.
But Robert Hooke wasn’t forgotten completely
and today we take a look at the man sometimes
described as the “Leonardo da Vinci of England.”
Early Life
Robert Hooke was born on July 28 (or July
18, going by the Old Style British calendar),
1635, in the village of Freshwater on the
Isle of Wight, the youngest of four children
to John Hooke and Cecily Gyles.
For the first part of his life, Hooke was
a frail and weak child and his parents had
little hope that he would survive.
Even so, his father took the time to provide
him with an education.
John Hooke was a priest with the Church of
England at Freshwater’s Church of All Saints.
He had two or three brothers who were also
ministers and expected young Robert to follow
in their footsteps.
From an early age, Robert Hooke showed his
family that he had other interests.
He was fascinated with mechanical devices
and toys and enjoyed taking them apart and
putting them back together again.
Still a child, Hooke built a ship about a
yard long which had proper rigging and could
sail and even had some small guns that would
fire.
On another occasion, he completely disassembled
an old brass clock to see how it worked and
created a functioning replica out of wood.
Also during childhood, Hooke picked up another
interest that would serve him well in life
- drawing.
The story comes to us courtesy of the book
Brief Lives by 17th century writer and natural
philosopher John Aubrey, one of the main sources
for Hooke’s early years.
A painter named John Hoskyns came to Freshwater
to draw pictures for an unspecified nobleman.
Young Hooke saw him in action and wanted to
give it a shot.
He did not have the right supplies so he had
to improvise.
Robert collected chalk, coal, and a red pigment
called ruddle, ground them together and placed
the mixture on a wooden platter.
He then took a pencil and began copying the
pictures that the family had around the house.
Education
Even though it became clear that Robert would
not go down the path of the church like his
father and uncles, John Hooke still wanted
to ensure that his son had the means to pursue
his profession of choice.
When John Hooke died in 1648, he left Robert
an inheritance of either forty or one hundred
pounds, depending on the source, so he could
secure an apprenticeship.
At first, it seemed like Hooke was destined
to be an artist.
He became an apprentice to Sir Peter Lely,
a Dutch painter who was one of the premiere
portraitists of his time.
He also studied with Samuel Cowper, a man
described by Aubrey as the “prince of limners
of this age.”
A limner was someone who illuminated manuscripts
i.e. decorated them with drawings, borders,
and initials.
Hooke’s foray into the art world did not
last long.
He discovered that the smell of oil colors
exacerbated the headaches that he suffered
from since childhood so, instead, he enrolled
at the Westminster School in London under
headmaster Richard Busby.
Here, Hooke learned Latin and Greek and got
his first taste of geometry.
Early Years at Oxford
Always looking to expand his horizons, Hooke
also took an interest in music and had twenty
lessons on the organ.
This was enough to secure him a spot as a
chorister at Christ Church College in Oxford
around 1653.
There, he came under the influence of some
of the most accomplished scientists of that
era: Robert Boyle, Dr Thomas Willis, John
Wilkins, Christopher Wren.
Eventually, he enrolled to study at Wadham
College.
Hooke himself later described these Oxford
days as the period of his life which cemented
his love of science.
We do have limited knowledge of Hooke’s
scientific contributions during these early
stages.
He served as a chemistry assistant, first
to Willis and then to Boyle.
According to his journal, Hooke designed and
built an air pump which Boyle used in his
experiments with the pneumatic engine.
He also came up with a variety of designs
which are lost to history regarding “the
art of flying.”
He presented these to John Wilkins who found
them impractical, but ingenious.
Hooke’s most significant invention at this
time, though, had to be the anchor escapement.
This was a small cog fitted to pendulum clocks
which helped maintain the swing and made the
clock more accurate by giving a small push
with each swing.
Hooke continued his studies of timepieces
as the years went on and, around 1660, also
created the balance spring for pocket watches.
It should be mentioned, though, that some
believe that credit for this invention is
due to Dutch scientist Christiaan Huygens.
At the same time, some historians argue that
Hooke deserves partial recognition for Boyle’s
Law, an experimental gas law described and
named by his employer at the time, Robert
Boyle.
The reasoning behind this is that Hooke designed
and built most of the apparatus used in Boyle’s
experiments.
The Curator of Experiments at the Royal Society
Something important happened in 1660 - the
Royal Society was born.
One of the oldest learned societies still
in existence today, it eventually became the
first national scientific society in the world.
Unofficially, it existed for a couple of decades
prior to it becoming a formal organization
and receiving a royal charter from King Charles
II.
Initially, it consisted of various scientists
who got together to discuss ideas and experiments.
Most were part of the Gresham College group
who, as the name implies, met at Gresham College
in London.
Eventually, twelve of these scholars formed
a committee and founded the Royal Society
of London for Improving Natural Knowledge.
This was a bit of a mouthful, though, so,
by the time the king granted them their charter
in 1662, they were already known simply as
the Royal Society with William Brouncker serving
as their first president.
Now, Robert Hooke was not among the original
twelve founders, but some of his friends and
mentors were such as Robert Boyle, Christopher
Wren, and John Wilkins.
Therefore, it wasn’t surprising that Hooke
was among the first new additions to the club.
In November 1662, he became Curator of Experiments
at the Royal Society.
This was described as a position that only
Hooke could fill as he was required to demonstrate
three or four experiments at every meeting
and, at first, he wasn’t even paid to do
it.
Yet Hooke acquitted himself marvelously of
his duties as he finally had a scientific
outlet for all the ideas he accrued over the
years and, as an audience, he had his most
brilliant peers who were in the best position
to judge and appreciate his work.
Hooke’s contributions were one of the main
reasons why the society flourished during
its early stages.
Consequently, he was appointed Curator for
life and, also, was granted another position
of Cutlerian Lecturer in the Mechanical Arts
so he may receive another salary from funds
provided by Sir John Cutler.
And if this didn’t keep Hooke busy enough,
in 1665 he also became the Professor of Geometry
at Gresham College.
Micrographia
Among the many accolades we can ascribe to
Robert Hooke, we can add the popularization
of microscopes to the list.
In 1665, he published the first major work
in history on microscopy titled Micrographia
or, to give it its original, full name, Micrographia:
or Some Physiological Descriptions of Minute
Bodies Made by Magnifying Glasses.
With Observations and Inquiries Thereupon.
Even though the title was a tad long-winded,
the book was a hit.
It showed the world that Robert Hooke was
one of the preeminent scholars of his time
and it also helped solidify the status of
the Royal Society as this was its first major
publication.
The politician and famed diarist Samuel Pepys
labeled Micrographia “the most ingenious
book that ever I read in my life.”
Inside the book, people could see for the
first time close-up, detailed drawings of
insects and plants which were done by Hooke
himself, therefore giving us a glimpse at
his skill as an artist, as well.
The images were accompanied by insightful,
somewhat artful descriptions.
Hooke’s most famous illustration, the flea,
for example, was described as being a “little
busie Creature...adorn’d with a curiously
polish’d suit of sable Armour...and multitudes
of sharp pinns, shap’d almost like Porcupine’s
Quills.”
Some entries were peppered with humor such
as the instance where Hooke described how
he got an ant drunk so that it may sit still
and allowed to be examined.
The scientist claimed he gave the insect brandy
which “knock’d him down dead drunk, so
that he became moveless”, only to revive
and run away after about an hour.
It wouldn’t be completely out of the question
to regard Hooke and his Micrographia as a
science popularizer, trying to bring knowledge
to the masses a few centuries before his time.
The microscope used for these examinations
was notable in of itself.
Hooke did not build it.
He outsourced this task to a famed London
instrument maker named Christopher Cock.
Hooke did modify and refine it, though, by
attaching a screw-operated focusing mechanism
of his own design, as well as adding a water
lens which could aim a bright pinpoint of
light on the smallest of targets.
Another thing worthy of mention in Micrographia
was the first use of the biological term “cell”
which denoted the basic structure which all
organisms are made out of.
Hooke coined the word while looking at a piece
of bark from a cork tree under his microscope.
He described it as being “perforated and
porous, much like a honeycomb.”
It was made out of little boxes which Hooke
called “cells” because they reminded him
of the rooms of monks inside a monastery.
Micrographia was a perfect example of how
Hooke’s mind worked.
He was a man of many interests and he developed
them all at the same time.
He wasn’t one to focus his attention on
just one thing.
Even though the book was intended as a presentation
of microscopy, it also described distant planetary
bodies which Hooke observed with his telescope.
It also presented his examination of fossilized
wood and Hooke’s associated ideas which
resembled an early version of the . He also
talked about the wave theory of light and
other scientific interests which had nothing
to do with the original purpose of Micrographia.
Hooke also mentioned his ideas on combustion.
At a time when other scientists were adopting
the theory of phlogiston, a fire-like component
which they thought existed in combustible
elements, Hooke opined that the process was
determined by a substance which was mixed
with air.
Although this is pure speculation, some modern
scholars believe that, if Hooke had pursued
this line of inquiry more fervently, he would
have discovered oxygen a hundred years earlier.
Robert Hooke, Architect
Although Hooke was, undoubtedly, a scientist,
he actually made more money in his lifetime
from his side job as an architect.
On September 2, 1666, London was ravaged by
a great fire which burned down most of the
medieval part of the city.
The blaze lasted for five days and consumed
over 13,000 structures, most of them houses.
Afterwards came the monumental task of rebuilding
the city.
The duty (and the ensuing accolades) fell
on Christopher Wren, someone who is literally
remembered as “the man who rebuilt London.”
This is not without merit.
Wren oversaw the construction of many important
buildings and structures.
He designed 52 new churches, including his
magnum opus, St. Paul’s Cathedral.
Wren was aided in his endeavor by Robert Hooke
who served as his chief assistant and the
new Surveyor to the City of London.
But while Wren’s name is now inexorably
tied to the architectural landscape of London,
Hooke’s contributions are seldom remembered
even though he surveilled and certified nearly
3,000 new foundations between 1667 and 1672.
In his own time, John Aubrey gave Hooke credit
for building the Royal College of Physicians,
Bethlem Royal Hospital, and Montagu House,
among others.
Even he did not know the full extent of Hooke’s
input, merely noting that Hooke was “much
made use of” when it came to designing new
structures.
It is hard to say with any certainty what
the dynamic was between the partnership of
Wren and Hooke.
Some modern historians even argue that Hooke
was the more important partner because it
was his expertise in mechanics which made
many of the new buildings possible.
We will probably never know for certain the
extent of the influence that Hooke had on
the landscape of London.
Hooke’s Law
Hooke’s lasting contribution to physics
is the law of elasticity that shares his name.
Hooke’s Law states that the force needed
to compress or extend a spring by some distance
is proportional to that distance.
The formula for this principle is F=-kX, where
F is the force applied to the spring, X is
the distance the spring compresses or expands
and k is the spring constant which denotes
its stiffness.
The formula is typically presented with a
negative value to show that the force exerted
by the spring opposes its displacement.
What might be more interesting to us, however,
was the way in which Hooke presented his new
principle.
We are not exactly sure when Hooke first came
up with it.
He had made claims about developing it as
far back as 1660, but he published it in 1678.
Two years prior, however, he gave everyone
a teaser in another book of his titled Descriptions
of Helioscopes.
He listed ten new discoveries and inventions
which he intended to present in the near future.
One of them was “The true Theory of Elasticity
or Springiness, and a particular Explication
thereof in several Subjects in which it is
to be found: And the way of computing the
velocity of Bodies moved by them.
ceiiinosssttuv.”
That last bit was not a typo, by the way,
it was an anagram.
Two years later, he revealed that it meant
“Ut tensio, sic vis” which was Latin for
“as the extension, so the force.”
You might consider it a bit odd that Hooke
went to such lengths, but it was not completely
unheard of in those days to conceal your workings
behind anagrams, cyphers, or some other kind
of hidden message.
The idea was that, by publicly presenting
a theory in this way, the scientist established
priority without revealing too much information.
Afterwards, they were free to keep working
on their project for months, years, even decades,
until it was fully fleshed out and ready to
present to the world.
If, in the meantime, another researcher unveiled
the same idea, the initial scientist had proof
that they started work on the subject first.
There are quite a few important discoveries
and inventions whose originators are under
doubt because multiple scientists worked on
them at the same time.
Hence, Hooke’s use of the anagram, a strategy
that had been employed by other prominent
scientists such as Newton, Galileo, or Huygens.
A Rivalry with Newton
As you can see, Robert Hooke was incredibly
accomplished, yet he enjoys only a fraction
of the renown of his great contemporaries.
But why is that?
You know the old saying “history is written
by the victor?”
In this case, it could simply be that Hooke
picked a fight with the wrong guy.
Setting aside Hooke’s many talents, it is
important to remember that he was still a
man full of foibles.
It seems that he was particularly prickly
when he perceived that others tried to take
credit for something he came up with.
The problem was that Hooke often moved on
from one idea to another if he did not perceive
it to be important enough or something he
could use to patent and profit.
This meant that a lot of his notions were
undeveloped and never advanced past the stage
of scribbles on a piece of paper.
It would be a little like crediting da Vinci
with the flying machine because he made a
drawing of one.
Unsurprisingly, this attitude led to several
feuds with fellow scholars.
We already mentioned in passing that he and
Christiaan Huygens argued over who developed
a spring for watches first.
He also quarreled with a German theologian
and scientist named Henry Oldenburg.
But Hooke’s greatest rivalry, one that had
a profound effect on his reputation, was with
Isaac Newton.
The relationship between the two turned sour
in 1672 when Newton presented his notions
on light and color.
Hooke insisted that Newton’s work was based
on ideas of his which he developed in 1665.
This quarrel was only the appetizer, though,
as the main course came in 1687 when Isaac
Newton published Philosophiae Naturalis Principia
Mathematica or, simply, the Principia, arguably
the most famous book in the history of science.
Among other seminal principles, the Principia
contained Newton’s law of universal gravitation,
an inverse square law that showed how planetary
motion worked.
It was a landmark moment in physics, but Hooke
accused Newton of plagiarism.
It is actually pretty hard to establish how
much credit, if any, should go to Hooke.
By Newton’s own admission, he corresponded
with Hooke on the matter, but he maintained
that the latter never provided any new information.
He might have concluded that an inverse square
law governed the motion of the planets, but
he never produced any proof for it even though
he claimed to have it.
This point of view was corroborated by Edmond
Halley, another esteemed scientist known today
for Halley’s Comet.
He said that he asked for proof from both
Hooke and Newton, but only the latter delivered.
Halley later encouraged Newton to write the
Principia and financed its publication out
of his own pocket.
French astronomer Alexis Clairaut was more
tactful when dismissing Hooke’s claims,
saying that they showed us “what a distance
there is between a truth that is glimpsed
and a truth that is demonstrated.”
What Did Hooke Look Like?
Hooke’s rivalry with Newton had a negative
effect on his image, as well as his standing
in the scientific world.
Some of his later lectures reveal that he
never conceded the point that he came up with
the inverse square law first.
In one of those lectures, he said “...concerning
those properties of gravity which I myself
first discovered and showed to this Society
and years since, which of late Mr Newton has
done me the favour to print and publish as
his own inventions.”
Hooke gained a reputation of being bitter
and disgruntled.
He died in 1703 of an unspecified illness
and was buried at St Helen’s Bishopsgate,
although the exact location is unknown.
Soon afterwards, another Royal Society member
named Richard Waller published a collection
of Hooke’s posthumous works and included
a short biography where he described him as
being “melancholy, mistrustful, and jealous.”
This biography, the only one from a contemporary,
influenced all those that followed, but we
do not know the relationship between Hooke
and Waller.
As for Newton, he became President of the
Royal Society the same year that Hooke died
and it is said that he took steps to ensure
that the world would forget his former rival.
This may have included the destruction of
the only known portrait of Robert Hooke so
that even his likeness would be lost to history.
But before we go on besmirching Newton’s
good name, we should stress that there is
no solid evidence that he ever did this or
even that the portrait existed in the first
place other than a few mentions.
Some have speculated that Hooke never wanted
to sit for a portrait because he had a weak
and misshapen body due to his childhood illness.
Indeed, today we have no idea what he looked
like.
This is the most famous representation of
Hooke based on the few available descriptions,
but you might be surprised to learn that this
painting, done by Rita Greer, is only 15 years
old.
She is one of the people who, in recent years,
have undertaken efforts to restore Robert
Hooke to his rightful place in the pantheon
of Britain’s greatest scholars.